Black History Month you findan
ridiculous why oh you're going to
relegate my history to our month oh come
on what do you do with
yours which month is White History
Month yes dude speechless this is Morgan
Freeman's version ofor I'm sorry sorry
sorry don't relate my my history to a
mon well the
oh I'm
Jewish try to Trump
them I'm Jewish I don't know if you know
what's going on over there right now
okay which month is Jewish history slam
into Oblivion dude unbelievable keeps
diing further and further into the hole
who's this guy the guy what's that guy's
name what Mike Wallace yeah yeah yeah
yeah there isn't one oh
oh acting Morgan Freeman is so dope dude
oh oh oh so there's not one why not do
you want one no no I don't either oh I
mean bating them dude you want one he
was like if the guy was like actually
yeah I would like to have June people
like oh so now you're [__]
diminishing the
blacks I don't want a black history mon
smashed it a baby black history is
American history how are we going to get
rid of racism on stop talking about
it I'm going to stop calling you a white
man yeah and I'm going to ask you to
stop calling me a black
man I know you as Mike Wallace you know
me as Morgan Freeman you smashed it
smashed it into Oblivion dude nobody's
made a better
point in the history of points
dude wait actually that deserves to be
watched again Black History Month you
find ridiculous I like how Mike Wallace
is
like you find Black History Month
ridiculous but how are we going to stop
racism like it's February that is the
the [__] dark night that's going to
[__] come save racism you know well
how are we going to stop racism you guys
got the shortest
month why why you're going to relegate
my history to a month worked on that
response was ready says it on set all
the time by the way you know to like the
boom guy that's February you got
anything you want to say about that what
do you mean what do you know what it is
you know what month it is it's black
history month right well you going to
relegate my history down to a month no I
don't know you brought it up so fire
this guy oh come on what do you do with
yours which month is Right history
stunned stunned him come on tell me oh
God dud mik Wallace met his match he met
his [__] match dude and it's Morgan
Freeman he met his match and it's the
[__] character in Batman you never
remember his name dude he met his
[__] match and it's from the
star of Along Came a Spider he [__]
met his match
dude I'm
Jewish to took that was his final he
knew after that if morg had more to say
he was cooked dude Mike Mike Wallace is
cooked he's I'm GNA throw my Jewish
thing he if morg if he says I'm Jewish
and then here's Mike Wallace knows ah
I'm I'm a piece of jerk chicken I'm
cooked dude okay which month is Jewish
History Month there we go there isn't
one oh yep defeated oh why not do you
want one no no all right I don't
either I don't want a black is mon
acting so good
dude awesome wow dude Morgan
Freeman
he